at eight eastern end pacific on c-span's
q a
american perspectives continues now with
a tribute to hunter s thompson
the author of many books and countless
articles died earlier this year
he's credited with influencing a
generation of journalists
in april a few of his friends and
colleagues gathered at the national
press club to discuss the life and
career of hunter s thompson
this is about 45 minutes
wait
okay
welcome back from intermission
uh thank you for staying all four of you
uh this is the important part uh this is
the part of the night where
hopefully we find out more about a guy
who uh
has been kind of like the beacon for me
you know i'm i'm kind of a cross between
hunter thompson and charles kuralt you
know that's
that's how i but uh not enough drugs
apparently
uh i'd like to bring up the rest of the
panel if that's okay
uh he's co-editor rolling stone tribute
issue to hunter thompson while working
at rolling stone with hunter his job was
described as part editorial assistant
and part cabana boy ladies and gentlemen
please welcome mr corey
seymour former press secretary to walter
mondale editor of the hill and just
returned from baghdad al isal
and you is al coming
buddy you're behind me thank you
scared the hell out of me
former press secretary to robert kennedy
mcgovern's campaign manager in 1972 vice
chairman of the hill and noton hill and
noten please welcome frank markowitz
and a man who probably knew him better
than most
uh former editor of the aspen daily news
he worked with hunter in his last
several books
and please welcome
mr curtis robinson
can we lose frank
did we lose frank
all right now the first thing i think we
should do is you guys
should tell us what you were doing when
you heard that hunter had passed away
what date was it
it was the 20th
of uh i think february
and uh i was in uh
you were in the right area code weren't
i was in the french quarter
uh with the guy who made the film of
hunter the film
breakfast with hunter
and
we were all going to go out there on
monday
but that didn't work out so well
the first calls i got were from the
media and then i got a call from the
sheriff and uh
then the reality started to sink in
that's where i was
al where were you
actually i was um getting ready to go
out to aspen i was going to go out i
usually go out
every year my brother-in-law's got a
condo in beaver creek and i go out and
spend a week in skiing and then i always
go over to aspen and spend a night with
hunter
and i was actually getting ready to do
that in the following week and i'd
talked to curtis about going out there
he was going to be out there i think
and
then i turned on npr one morning and i
heard a reference to hunter thompson's
death and i was shocked so i just talked
to him about two weeks ago and said i
was going to be out there and he said
well you know come by and see me which i
always did so
that's where i was corey
i was hanging out in brooklyn new york
where i live i was having dinner with
friends and uh
one of the friends asked me i friend
like a certain number of my friends is
sort of fascinated by my connection with
hunter and
i'm getting married in a few months and
the friend
said do you think you're going to invite
hunter to your wedding and i thought you
know that's a really good question i
really i haven't spoken to him in a few
months
i should give him a call and i never i
didn't call him that night um the next
morning woke up and checked my email i
had emails from friends in russia
friends in the uk and friends you know
all over the country saying
you know but sir that's how i found out
um and immediately kind of sent an email
a condolence sort of email to john
winner the founder and editor of rolling
stone and uh
shortly thereafter got a phone call
basically saying how soon can you get
here you know to put together the issue
that we did
and we worked 17 hours a day for the
next 11 days straight putting together
the issue that we did that's how i found
out it was a great issue mr manquits
when where were you when you heard that
mr thompson had died
i think i was home
i was home
my son called me he and i had
shared a lot of time with hunter
and
he said i've got sad news and he told me
about it on the phone
do you remember the first time you met
him
the first time i met hunter yeah
well it was in the mcgovern campaign um
george mcgovern introduced us
uh and he kept referring to hunter as
the sheriff
he kept calling him share because you
know he'd run for sheriff out there in
woody creek
i think it was only as successful as
mcgovern
so they shared something
but
i met him there and
we got along very well
after the campaign was over we took a
wonderful flight from uh
evansville indiana to new york in a
chartered airplane which you can all
read about and fear and lobbing on the
campaign trail
it's just about the only
true story in the camp in that book
um i've said before i'll say again that
book
is the most accurate and least factual
account
of the campaign
[Applause]
people uh
we like to put people down now and then
who are very serious
we say well yeah they've got the words
but they don't have the
music hunter thompson had the music and
not often the words
mr isil do you remember the first time
you met him i'm sorry do you remember
the first time you met hunter i do it
was 1972 during the mcgovern campaign
and we were out on somewhere in the
campaign trail and first thing i
remember about hunter is that we went
into a bar to have a drink afterwards
and he
washed in his pocket and pulled out a
half a dozen red and blue pills he said
you want some and i said no i don't do
that but
that was my first encounter with him and
for some reason he hit it off with me he
called me one of his few straight
friends
i wrote a column about him uh after he
died called him
sue generous he was of his own kind
literally there was nobody it was unique
there was nobody like him um i i think
frank mentioned fear and loathing 72
marty tolchin who was the
founder and first publisher and
editor-in-chief of the hill
which i helped start 10 years ago
it was from the new york times and he
surprised me by saying that that was the
best book written about the 72 campaign
it really was
yeah so his legacy is as a writer i
think more than anything else i mean for
all his strange habits and so for
excesses and so forth he was a a
wonderful writer and a a literary genius
i think
but it was it was hunter who said about
writing that it was like sex
mostly fun for amateurs
do you remember the first time you met
him
i met hunter when i was editor of the
aspen daily news
[Music]
i was ducking a bbc film crew which put
me in hunter's good graces because he
always
he always gave you the benefit of the
doubt if you were ducking tv which
which we're not doing right now he
considered that
a sign of character frankly
not so much tonight
but uh yeah i met him in uh i was the
editor of the aspirant news we did some
politics together
and uh when i came um
when the decision came to uh move from
aspen to washington
uh he said you know
you probably uh
and a lot of us consulted hunter
uh
when you knew him well he was he was
someone you would call and ask for
advice on everything from mutual funds
to uh should i go to washington
he said you know everyone should go to
washington for uh uh a couple years
um
i'm working now on five i think he would
consider that uh
perhaps they should send someone for me
but um
yeah you know uh he was he was someone
who you could call and ask that kind of
question where should i go where should
i live
um
uh
who should i vote for
that kind of thing
you could ask him that
corey you remember the first time that
you ran into him uh yeah i do i was
working at rolling stone in 1992
uh as an assistant on the features desk
and
a lot of people have asked me since uh
you know why was i selected to be sort
of hunters new york based assistant or
cabiana boy or
butt monkey is another way of putting it
um
c-span it had nothing to do yeah
a lot of people think it's because i had
a strong liver or something it's just
because i happened to be the assistant
on that desk and was sent to pick him up
uh out at the airport he was just in
town for uh the 25th anniversary party
of rolling stone
and we missed him at the gate he walked
right by us
we were
waiting
wait a minute wait a minute you walked
right by you what you missed hunter
thompson we missed hunter tops and i was
there with john's driver who said he had
known hunter for you know going on 10
years or something like that and i'd
suddenly realized when i was in the car
heading out to the airport that i didn't
really know what hunter looked like and
i think i was expecting like a explosion
what kind of thing and like a ralph
stedman character
and he walked right by us he looked a
little different than other people but
what year was this what 92. the airport
is that we're six foot four guys in
black dark glass he didn't have the
whole get up hill now boy hat and a
raven sweet and a bottle of wild turkey
in his hand
you don't recognize him do you pick him
up at the new orleans airport
at that time we ended up catching i
caught up with him down at baggage claim
he was surrounded by this uh hard
halliburton luggage that he used all the
time and i was very nervous he was a
huge you know literary hero of mine and
here i am meeting him and he sticks his
hand out he's sitting on the floor he
sticks his hand out and i'm all nervous
and i walk up to shake it and he
basically nearly
he yanked me really hard almost to the
floor and said no help me up god damn it
[Laughter]
and we started got rolling from there
and then in the back seat of the car
heading to his hotel um
yeah i think he knew that i was a little
on edge about the whole experience and
he handed me this that he had this
plastic bottle clear plastic bottle with
half filled with this sort of orange
liquid and he handed it to me and had
this weird look in his eye and he said i
think you need some of this
and i
i just i just kind of knew it this is
the test this is what he must do to
everybody that you know he meets for the
first time he's there to help him out
and
and i just took a big swig of it fully
expecting just to start seeing trails
going down
the bqe and just tripping out of my mind
and it was just orange juice you know
that's
that's the way he works and um moments
later we were in this hotel and hours
later um
nearly throwing large framed pictures
off the hotel window
you know it's going onward and upward
from there
it's kind of ironic that we're here
paying tribute to hunter thompson at the
national press club because curtis and i
can tell you we were we we were going to
bring him here he wanted to come here
and speak at the press club and we'd
been working on this for three or four
months and uh
originally it was going to come after
the election and he was coming in
january and then february it kept
getting sliding back but curtis can tell
you that the difficult logistics of
dealing with hunter thompson they get
very complex uh i just thought you'd get
him a first class ticket and fly him out
here but no you got to fly him on a
personal jet
and sean penn was going to provide the
jet thing it put him up at his best
hotel which is the four seasons and then
you gotta make sure he's got a uh
copious supply of heinekens and chivas
regal
and uh your bill runs up very quickly so
uh
and then you have to have a keeper like
curtis to make sure that he gets to
where he's supposed to be
to the press club
so it's uh complicated incidentally the
picture over here to the right is one
that i took last march of hunter and
curtis and me out at uh at hunter's
place in owl creek
and um that same that same trip i happen
to have my 30 some year old nephew from
iowa with me invited him out to go
skiing with me
and uh like the younger generation he's
uses marijuana and so he
he not not the entire younger generation
but the hunter younger generation i
would say yeah
he always wanted to meet hunter and so
we walked into hunter's house and he
immediately pulled out a joint and
offered a hundred and hundred lit up and
he this is c-span so i gotta clean up
his language he said he said man where
did you get this
stuff he says this is better than
anything i can get
which made my nephew's day
he did my drugs
hunter did my coke
[Music]
private joke
was it was the whole drug thing it
wasn't
over embellished it was part of who he
was
uh i worked with hunter on a couple of
the books and i worked with him for 10
years and
my hand to god hunter had a gift for
understatement
the
i remember we were working on the first
letters book and and and i got
interested in the first letters book uh
i had a day job at the time running a
date a daily newspaper
and um i was very interested in because
the thing i wanted to know was this
yeah yeah he's hunter thompson now
he gets pulled over by a cop and he
brings in four or five attorneys that
we've we've seen on court tv
and uh some poor son of a [ __ ] that
pulled him over is now going to have his
entire life uh
i say what was he like when he was like
me what was he like when he was broke
you know he was he you know his tags
were expired
and
other things
so i went back to the letters
hunter kept everything he kept letters
from high school
and uh doug brinkley uh
it's a tangent but doug brinkley came in
uh
hunter said i've got i've got some
letters
so poor doug brinkley came in um a noted
historian and thought you know he's
gonna find a few hundred letters
he finds
what we think now five thousand letters
starts in high school month by month for
his entire life hunter knew he'd be
famous early on so
so i go into that and and my question is
burning my question is this my question
is what was he like when he was me when
he was broke and he was some reporter at
some little podunk paper and
he gets pulled over the state patrol and
and i've got to tell you
he was hunter early on man it was like
there was just no doubt and
i remember going through
the letters they would they would let
you um
i was going through boxes
we came up on the vegas thing and and i
ran into these lists it was like in
hunter's hand which i'd learned to
recognize
drug list car
drug list room
and if you read the vegas book
and you read the drug list and you're
like
my god could that possibly
trust me i've seen in his own hand
those were notes from from the field and
yes would be my answer
and because that's something people ask
me they say how much is true and how
much
i've got to tell you
again my hand to god gift for
understatement because what we always
back down
uh
maybe it never got weird enough for him
but jesus it got weird enough for most
of us it got pretty weird
i remember uh hunter and i were
reporting uh a story that turned into uh
polo is my life which rolling stone did
in 94. and we were driving route around
on long island uh there was a the u.s
open of polo was happening out there and
uh we're hunkered down at the garden
city hotel
uh really bizarre things going on there
um
you know he's sort of thinking it's a
good idea for me to walk around the
lobby at four in the morning with this
blow up sex doll
she's my girlfriend and see what happens
and we do that but uh we eventually
we eventually have to get over to
huntington to the hilton there to meet
ginger baker the former drummer from
cream who's a polo player of course
uh and
we're running late uh you know we're
driving down the highway uh about 105
miles an hour roughly uh he drives in my
experience with
these two fingers and a thumb on the
steering wheel these two fingers have a
cigarette this hand has got his shivvus
uh
we're i'm holding up uh i don't know how
far we can go with c-span here a certain
sort of pipe to his lips uh
and it's just you know all happening at
105 miles an hour and then we get
to the hotel to meet ginger and we
immediately step outside of the parking
lot and uh
hunter has his skull shaped pipe and
he's lighting that up with ginger and
hunter before he does this hands me the
classic shaving kit that i think a lot
of people have read hunter know what
that means uh
he really does have one he really does
use it for what you think he would and
he just hands it to me and says if you
see any cops or any security just grab
this and take off running
and i just made a decision right there
i'm not going to do that you know i'm
going to
i'm going to drop it and maybe take off
running
things got a little frightening
sometimes around him but in always sort
of a fun way uh
people always always say you know want
me to summarize the whole experience
and it's kind of impossible but it's
really like the best time of your life
you know these times but only in
retrospect because at the time
they're just hellish i mean they're fun
but they're
a nightmare at the same time but
now i you know i relish all the memories
and all the stories did the myth take
over the man do you think
the myth of hunter did they consume the
man
no i don't think so because i think
that's what he was from the beginning as
you say i think he was i mean the myth
was was the reality
much
doubt about that you know every once in
a while in the in the 80s i guess
i would start to get his mail
at home i mean addressed to him care of
me
no advanced notice huh which meant what
what sort of stuff was in that map
mail you know junk mail and ads personal
letters and what it meant to me was that
he was gonna come
stay he was on his way and sure enough
two or three two or three days later
doorbell and ring and there he is huh
out on the front porch
usually with a bottle of wild turkey
ready and one of those kids
ready to move in for a few days
al what do you think
uh to the years that come
to to his legends yeah
i don't think so i mean i think he i i i
don't want to psychoanalyze my i looked
up on google a week or so after he died
and there were 5 million some hits on
him so there were stories all over the
world in fact i put together a
compilation of a lot of this their
coverage
and sent it to his widow uh
and to curtis and others but uh i think
you know i think he as i said he was sue
a generous there was nobody else like
him he was he was a legend himself maybe
he
maybe in his last year or two he he
[Music]
he started to believe in some of this
and maybe i don't know but i i do know
that um
one of the maybe three or four years ago
when i went to visit him i hadn't seen
him for three or four years and and i
walked in and he gave me a very a big
bear hug and that was uncharacteristic
of him i think
and he told me i did an interview with
him and i did it
in the hill it was about four years ago
and i said hunter thompson's alive and
well in in aspen and he hadn't had been
kept a fairly low profile he hadn't
heard much of him but he had he was
involved in this great crusade for lisa
allman the woman who was arrested and
charged with
murder because her skinhead boyfriend
killed a cop in in denver and he that
was his big cause and
he gave me a great interview and he told
me he said he had a grandson and he
calls me ace
it was very very poignant and touching
almost but
you think these people or journalists in
america owe a debt
to him or have they been
perverted by the hunter
well the worst worst mistaken journalist
can make is try to imitate hunters as
most great writers but but i think that
he certainly influenced a lot of them
and and uh
i think that
i'm sorry
you are perverted
thank you thank you for your perversion
well
i think he influenced a lot of uh
journalists and i think his influence
will continue
but you know the thing about hunter is
uh
for riders
he he uh
he pushed the envelope out there um i
would also say that the thing about
hunter that was so weird
is that he would come up with this off
the wall thing he would say
lisa lawman's a great case he would come
and he would say
here's what we're going to do
we're going to march on a road of bones
and this woman the supreme court's going
to give her a new trial and you're like
she was involved in the cop killing man
you know bill clinton came to town yeah
um
okay
let's just let's just go with that let's
just assume that's true um
last week
a couple weeks after uh hunter died uh
the colors colorado supreme court
said that lisa loman gets a new trial
there were so many times both on a
that's a big issue but there were small
issues he would come and say
uh
curtis you you have to help me they're
uh they're going to put in a regional
sewage plant in woody creek and i'm like
there's like
a couple dozen people in woody creek
there's gonna be no regional sewage
and then you would look around and then
you would talk to someone in that case
the the former mayor and he would say
i have the plans you want to see them
yeah they're like how the hell do you
know that and he's like he was as
intuitive a political mind as you could
humanly imagine they were always
threatening to widen the highway right
that was
they're going to put another lane in the
road they said we can't let them do that
politics is the art of controlling
your environment
and he took that did he not
sure
i think he uh i i don't like the phrase
pushing the envelope because i'm not
sure what it means but
it means the bag he brought to your
house
[Music]
i know about that on
you don't want to push it too far
but i think in terms of journalism he
really did free up a lot of people who
were looking for a reason to break loose
to write about things that
maybe they thought should be written
about but they didn't quite have the
courage to do it i thought he was quite
inspirational in that sense
you know because as the
as the 80s began to wear on and you know
this he he quieted down and the the um
his fan club felt free to
even embellish a little bit on what he
had done
and i think it was uh
i think it was a good thing for
journalism because it opened the
boundaries people said well i can write
like that a lot of people did there's
also a whole new generation of young
reporters and young people who are
reading him i think for the first time
and i see that among the young reporters
that we have i work with and they're
influenced by corey i think corey ought
to read a couple of these facts is the
notes that he that he wrote on his facts
as if they're if you can clean it up for
c-spanish
i would also just like to say i mean i
think
there's
in my mind there's no doubt that hunter
changed journalism irrevocably and
permanently in the world's a better
place for it
and there's something that he spoke
about a lot i mean certainly with me and
with other friends um
in later years recent years
there's
something you wish very much was that a
new
a new singular journalist or a group of
journalists would sort of step up and
step up to the plate and really you know
do what he did um not necessarily that
didn't you know like we've spoken about
earlier here that didn't mean try to be
hunter thompson it just meant
change journalism again do it again step
up to the plate and call it like you're
seeing it which is what he really did
um the faxes in question here uh were
sort of my original
introduction to hunter before i ever met
him
uh was working at rolling stone on this
25th anniversary issue where we
were publishing the best uh of what had
already been printed in rolling stone
for the you know previous years had to
send hunter some very routine faxes
about you know um do we have can we you
know here's the rights that we're buying
and here's how much we're paying you and
things like that
and then i had to write a very
straightforward bio of hunter you know
you know ran it by him you know he with
his approval hunters thompson is the
national affairs death chief a rolling
stone author of eight books you know
sort of straightforward thing
he sort of crosses the whole thing off
no
no and then
writes you cheap miserable screw head
don't ever write anything about me again
you'll be better off selling crack love
hunter
[Music]
the next page is a you know boilerplate
kind of you know we need this many words
from you he basically writes back fu
i'll sell it to another magazine for ten
dollars a word
and then the following uh it lays out
the three rights that we're hoping to
purchase from him he draws a gigantic x
through it
and writes eat blank and die
[Music]
charming man
and i've got to tell you uh i worked
with hunter for years
this was one of the editors and cabana
boys that he really liked
the other people got really harsh it was
sort of it was something that you'd
worried about worried about if you
didn't get these kind of faxes from
hunter kind of meant that he didn't like
you and if he didn't call you at home
and wake you up at four in the morning
on a tuesday and your girlfriend or
anybody else that you know might be
around it just sort of
once he got on that beat you stayed on
that beat and i left rolling stone at a
certain point and went to another
magazine
uh i was still on hunter beat and kind
of still was uh years and years later if
hunter came to town
and maybe needed to you know get his
himself organized you know get be
somewhere at a certain time i would
maybe be
like sort of on the hunter reserve or
something that was my weekend of service
or something there was a uh there's
always been this uh the first event i
did with hunter speaking being on the
hunter beat uh
a guy in aspen who who had done several
fundraisers he said look i had guys who
paid 500 a ticket in a room he said
i i've got to tell you this
you send anyone in to bring hunter to
the event
if they're not out in 20 to 30 minutes
write them off they're part of the
problem
[Laughter]
those of us who could function in that
environment
on the hunter beat where were were
golden in our and you could leave a
magazine
and they would call you and they would
say can you please help
[Music]
am i right totally right yeah
it's always fun being in around hotels
with him uh
you would think fun
it was fun
fun and hellish i mean you know yin yang
sort of thing we'd you know walk into
the car and they'd greet him as if you
know he was
[Music]
the president of the country or
something like i mean he was really well
known
at all the hotels he stayed he kept
moving from one to another from the
plaza to the carlyle to the four seasons
uh as he saw the level of security
uh at the front desk uh increasing at
each one he decided he needed more
security uh
and there's really no much uh there's no
more fun in the world than uh
getting a valet car with hunter uh when
he hands the valley guy his ticket
and maybe the valley took 10 minutes or
so to hunter
hunter was moving a little faster than i
was and uh he thought it was taking
maybe 40 minutes
and to see him throw
a real king hell fit in uh the lobby of
the garden city hotel
you know tall guy walking around holding
a tumbler of shivas screaming you know
i'm ben franklin which is the name he
assumed at hotels often i'm ben franklin
and i want my you know like expletive
expertise
sometimes in in in a bow to his kentucky
roots and i'm from kentucky he would
also be henry clay
he's gonna be missed and this is a great
um the the magazine i i don't know if
you guys have picked up the tribute
issue but uh you did a great job on that
thank you
[Applause]
but you know i i would like to hear from
frank about the uh
mcgovern campaign because um
i spent so many late nights drinking
whiskey with with hunter and uh
he was cynical you know he um
he liked clinton and then didn't uh
he was never a bush fan
he uh he liked johnny carter he liked
jimmy carter he wrote the law day speech
that was was part of the uh
jimmy carter mythology
uh yet he he was so defined by the
mcgovern
nixon
uh
campaign in some ways that
and you know that
and i i think the context of that was
and we have to remember what it was he
was writing for rolling stone which was
a magazine that had this this youth
demographic as we would say now
and it was when uh 18 year olds got the
vote and and we forget that we forget
that there was a magazine that
spoke to these folks so so all of a
sudden it would be like being a blogger
now where it's like oh that's that's the
king hell blogger from all time
we'll let him in
they let hunter in
am i right yeah he um
i think you're right i think that
campaign was really a shaping influence
for him um
well it was it was the 18 year old vote
it was rolling stone it was a war
it was above all richard nixon
who was really somebody a guy like
hunter well a guy like all the rest of
us could could really hate
hunter were you i used to go i used to
go to uh book signings where someone
come up and say
people would come up with a guy with
their son and they would say
uh you know
we uh
the only thing we agree upon is you and
and and nixon and he would say well
a common hatred will unite a family more
than a common love
but
but also mcgovern was a was a
the last of i think a breed of
campaigners i mean he was he was a
serious campaigner he wasn't looking for
campaign funds that came easily
um nobody ever said anything really bad
about it except maybe they thought he
was wrong or they thought he should have
done this or done that instead
but uh hunter loved him
and uh absolutely loved it and and
really had a feeling that that campaign
represented
a
division a time in america that he had
to be a part of and it really really hit
him when uh when mcgovern lost
he kept me going you know i think
probably knowing what i know and knowing
what i knew then i probably would have
given up on the campaign in july but
hunter kept us going
in what way well he thought we were
going to win
he he loved the crowds
he'd encouraged mcgovern at night after
the events were over
and
and that gets to be catching after a
while
and he was such a colorful fellow
compared to most of the rest of the
journalists
um
nothing personal also he believed
those those of you who have uh he
believed kickbacks with you he you're
exempted he believed every rumor he
heard
so he really did believe that hubert
humphrey had sent a private airplane to
las vegas to pick up a million dollars
from howard to use
and he will well maybe it was true
uh
it was only 500
he believed everything about nixon and
well who knows
but um
and of course watergate was beginning to
leak through the uh
the media
and uh he uh that campaign that campaign
really turned him on
well nixon was such a villain
yeah he was uh
you just had a look at him
what was it uh someone said he had a
face like a foot
yeah
and uh we i don't think say the people
who hate george bush don't hate
i mean they think they hate george bush
the way that people hated nixon but no
no that was visceral
yeah it was much it was much more
visceral back then
well it was also what you were saying it
was the change of the
the uh the generations i mean you could
tell what side a person was on across
the street but what clothes they were
wearing what their hair was cut like
that was a different time
also it was it was probably the last
campaign before television came to
dominate politics totally
um
100 never made the transfer to
television no too hot that's right
but for fox news
no but it was a it was a campaign in
which you cared about what people wrote
and hunter paid attention to that and
that was the last time that happened uh
the old days
hunter had hart
hunter at heart was a writer
and uh
i
and maybe i had a different experience
than other people but
i always found he knew you know he had a
standing invitation to go on letterman
um and and he wasn't
you know he did tv uh sparingly but i i
think well
um
and i could be tainted by the fact that
that when i met him he said you know
why don't you come out and have a
whiskey because anyone who ducks tv
cameras is a friend of mine
um
i don't think he
i i really believe that he thought the
written word
was still very important and that uh
he was somewhat appalled
by the fact that uh he saw so many uh
journalists
uh
and and other people doing
what he would say uh any damn thing they
could to get on tv
of course i'm saying that on c-span now
oh perhaps i'll just be quiet now
no he was really he was obsessed with
the written word there's nothing i mean
he he really believed that when he was
on his game that he was writing sort of
high poetry and there's nothing he loved
more than to have his work
read aloud whether it's by himself or
more often
by a cabana boy like me
not many people's work can handle being
read aloud
yeah
he it really it held up well when he
he knew he was on his game when he would
he really did hear a certain kind of
music when
his writing was working you know it was
it was it was that that's part of it but
it was it was more than that when we
were doing the first letters book we
would read letters that he had written
when he was 23 24 years old
and you'd read part of it and you'd miss
something something so obscure like the
difference between a and ann or
something
and then and he would be almost like
asleep it's three in the morning and you
think yeah i'll get away with that um
he would just go crazy like what
what the [ __ ] um
wow there what i'm watching my mom
um i'm use it marching on a road of what
and you're like uh
i said homes it's bones uh whatever it
was
it wasn't that he remembered the words
but i'm telling you from he could tell
it was how to scan a gazillion years ago
he didn't sing he's like
you're absolutely right it didn't sing
it wasn't it wasn't his
his tone his pitch and he would be and
he knew that
he knew that i mean on the most obscure
level imaginable
and um
when you read aloud
you had to read slowly
am i right very very very slowly
yes curtis because i know curtis i think
curtis knew him certainly knew him
better than anybody who was here
what it was that that drove him to
commit suicide i know he was physically
ailing and so forth what do you think
curtis i always tell people like yeah
yeah you know
i know that because i'm so
insightful
unfortunately i'm saving it for my
book
gonzo boy tell all scum sucker vol 1.
gonzo letters from the grave you know
that kind of thing
those who work with him would think
that's funnier than others um
you know
he was never one to stay when the party
was done
he had had enough uh
his
um
his body that he loved had begun to uh
diminish
you you had a tough trip to new orleans
and you just yeah you know i was in new
orleans with him a few weeks before he
killed himself i talked to him four days
before he killed himself
um
none of us thought hunter would
it was a bad week to say this we never
thought he would go the
uh
all right i'll be careful here
particularly in this room uh we never
thought he would go
the hospice route we never thought it
would go that uh that we'd have this
kind of thing
um
have you read his work
the question was was he depressed
uh
we
i personally i thought we had a couple
more years
did i think he was going to go into the
hospice at 78 or something no no no no
um
why did he pick
th the thing the question i have is why
did he pick that day i don't know it
could be because things were good
things were looking up you know um
rum diary was going to a movie and and
he loved that novel if you've not read
it read it
he wrote it when he was in his 20s it's
a it's a wonderful book
um why did he pick
that day instead of others um
i don't know
i i can't i can't tell you that i i
could speculate that
you know he wasn't um
he was always on his own terms
and he left on his own terms uh
people who understand uh depression and
other things said well that
and suicide they said that's [ __ ]
um
i don't know
um
his son says he was a warrior and a
champion
um i know juan thompson he's one of the
strongest people i've ever met he knew
his father intimately and
i've got to kind of go with that
gentleman we've got five minutes before
we get to get out of here
is there anything
you want to leave us with
just go back and read them carry a
bottle of chevis around with us anything
is anybody here was anybody here
surprised
that the end came by suicide
i i was not surprised that it came when
it did i didn't i wasn't
i sort of thought that's always what he
would do eventually he and i had worked
uh on some of these
biographical paragraphs for one story or
another at some point that i had faxed
him yet another one that he you know
crossed out and such but
eventually he wrote its own and it you
know said something effective you know
hunter s thompson is a brutal and
dangerous southern gentleman who lives
in a fortified compound outs in colorado
um
but at the end he had written something
like uh
he will die in a gigantic fireball on
top of a hundred thousand tons of tnt on
the eve of the millennium or something
like that and honestly i you know
i didn't really you know think about how
hunter would die but i mean i just
assumed that it would be some bizarre
kind of pop art spectacle or something
like that and i was
i was a little surprised at what seemed
like almost the
mundane nature of of what he did i must
say one evening i thought it was going
to be with me in an airplane
[Music]
we all thought that we uh
we um
we charted an airplane i'm trying i
can't remember why i guess there was no
there were no commercial flights that
suited both of us he was giving a
lecture and so was i
in um
i think evansville
indiana purdue
enough to make you commit suicide yeah
well if you think about it
and my my wife is a graduate of purdue
and
not tripp and
vance hartke was no longer in the senate
so the airline didn't fly directly from
evansville to washington
and it was very hard to get out so we
charted the airplane
because we
both were giving speeches at places that
would pay for at least half of the
airplane
and
we flew to new york
and hunter got more and more interested
in
the flight and the pilot
a small airplane
and when he got to new york he said to
the pilot let's take a look at central
park
which we did and then he kept saying to
the pilot lower
[Music]
and the pilot finally gave us a kind of
a tour of the metropolitan of the
metropolitan area and hunter loved it
and he kept urging him on you know now
let's let's look at the fulton fish
market
[Laughter]
and i must say i worried a little bit
that night i couldn't
couldn't quite figure out where it was
going to end but it ended up laguardia
it was okay
gentlemen i'm afraid our time is up
uh can we thank our panel
mr curtis robinson mr frank manquits
alizelle
corey seymour
thank you all for coming on behalf of
the national press club
uh hope we get to do more of these kinds
of events
have a drink tonight
excuse me can i have your attention
please
uh just so you know there is a reception
afterwards in the home and lounge we had
beforehand so if you want to stick
around uh chat with some of our
panelists
please join us to the side thank you
and if your name is david wallace you
have lost something very important that
you may not know about yet please come
to the membership table to claim it
that's good thank you all for coming
hold on
if you'd like a copy of any of tonight's
american perspectives programs you can